I'd like to take a second to talk about a pretty important concept in Math in
general, especially when we're talking about graphing. And that is symmetry. We
talked about this to a certain extent when we were dealing with quadratic
functions, like y equals x squared. We said that if you have a parabola like
this one, we know that we can draw a line that goes straight through its vertex,
such that, if you folded the problem in half along this line then it would map
directly onto itself. In other words, at any point along this middle line, this
axis of symmetry, the points on the parabola directly to the left or right of
it, are equally distant from the axis. So if I'm at this position for example,
this y value, then the distance in the extraction from here to here, is the same
in terms of absolute value, as the distance from here to here. Now it seems
looking at these other even functions, like a similar kind of symmetry applies
to them. One question is, do odd functions have symmetry as well? And, in both
cases, how do we mathematically express that symmetry. Now, I'm about to give
you a kind of complex quiz that's going to require a fair amount of critical
thinking and some new materials. So, this is going to definitely be a major
challenge problem. So, if we know that a point, that we are going to call x
comma y, is on a given graph. What if we find that the point negative x comma y
is also on that graph? What does that say about this graph? Does that mean that
is represent an even function, or an odd function, or neither of these? Think
about which of the graphs either on this plane or this plane, this property
applies to. And you can even test it out with real points.